yes war zone raided one minute 71
players still 1816 average rating time
handicapped 30 minute anybody can enter
the entry fee is just 20 cubits less
than ten nine eight coming up
tick tick tick here we go war zone Kings
is officially started right now double
the points c5 and c6 Queen here quick
kills hang on
don't you dare Castle you know you want
a castle watch over c5 I'm still gonna
play I should have played oh okay well
so much for that so much it's going this
direction maybe play here let's try it
now actually in the night here no that's
not how you recapture like this the
Queen is actually close to trapped she's
dead with check and then I recapture Oh
was this resigned time
hang on night I do not want you to get
there and sit there for any amount of
time light squares right here pawn push
like this give a check kill the bishop
next soon bishop gonna block him on both
of these ponds dark squares dark squares
and come on what do we have here get out
of there night there's gonna be a pawn
push okay wait check and then where's
the main meeting one threat yes quick
quick quick quick quick back determine
two two two a bunch of twos and a few
ones okay so far so good
one game
in a lot of time remaining are they
gonna pair me up
they are gonna pair me up let's roll
here okay let's go with this first and I
don't know why with the Queen
Oh get out of there Bishop and I'm gonna
look to trap that Bishop actually can I
make this happen
kick away one of the pieces the knight
has to go to a not so happy place space
a lot of space my knight coming in to
kill the bishop bishop killer coming up
structural damage light square
weaknesses over here pawn push a couple
times I want to get at this point and my
pawn wants to push to g6 actually as
soon as the Jeep on captures capture
captured Queen takes h5 pawn push is a
threat
okay my queen needs to go elsewhere
let's go this is falling and I'll just
back up I think okay now this is a fork
it's a killer fork night on the rook Oh
remove the defender with check and then
take the Queen this is a problem I'm
gonna resign they're letting the clock
tick matin one I got Queens on the board
where's the main meeting one two back to
term at six two sixes a couple fives and
a four okay Rob five two one
the points have been doubled it's
official and my opponent is officially
not moving 26 seconds and change yes a
quick resigner oh I could use those
points twelve six is okay twelve and
then a bunch of sixes okay d4 and a
capture no we got this coming up I'm
gonna try this
support that Center hopefully I get be
foreign and then have that pond make up
its mind make up your mind see pond that
way I could go forward okay now I have a
fork if that pond pushes yes I'm on the
Queen and the rook and okay this is let
me support my Center and get developed
let's trade a little bit why not I'm up
material interesting move with the
bishop there and I'm gonna do this cuz
I'm there at the end of it I'm on the
Queen if it's captured
let's support this support my knight
it's an in a good spot
but that Knights gonna take up a nice
post here just try this this could
follow though that could definitely fall
okay I'm on that night I could exploit
this pin on the Queen after the knight
moves and then I could take the rook
after it even if the night plays to be
four okay I have this there's no main
threat right
no made threats let's get the Queen's
off my queen wants to be on f7 oh I'm on
the Queen I must miss that lateral
movement
I must miss that I was ready to play
Queen f6 back to tournament twenty
twenty eighteen twelve twelve okay less
little less than twenty five minutes
remaining
okay Blumenfeld gambit oh is that a
mouse slip I think it might have been a
mouse slip now I'm defending it and I'm
gonna hang on to it here we go
this and then it's just that pawn pushes
then I just push here they're trying to
fishing pull me why is going on let's
play here pawn push actually night right
here in the center I'll double my pawns
and then I could play here Queen d7 as
well Bishop here Bishop here next
maybe I don't know what that moves doing
okay let's take Manos intake with the
bishop and then clean Oh pins pins pins
pins a knight goes here my queen is
defended this is actually working
it's okay with check get to this square
these two make coming up know made on
this square the Queen can't go to a spot
where she threatens g7 could play here
pretty quick unless the Queen takes the
bishop right here it mayn't next move
unless there's a queen check back to
tournament they resigned 30 got five
games in four games in okay what do we
have
can I get first place let's make it
happen here I know bad things are gonna
happen though I haven't I love what I'm
fumbling on my words I love I don't even
know what I'm trying to say I have a bad
feeling about it that's what I was
trying to say right there oh there goes
the bishop and I want to stop the
pressure against this pawn right here
he's gonna come under some heavy heat
heavy heat coming up let me Oh just
trade no no no no oh I got a free Queen
it's a free Queen resign they're gonna
resign come on you know you want to
resign get out of there Knight what am i
chasing that night away oh I got another
night not another night I got more
material more material that's how it
happens the knight is dead
Oh kitchen sink defense kitchen sink I'm
getting kitchen sink right here back to
tournament 42 42 28 20 a lot of players
right on my heels this is the first guy
played in the last tournament open a six
Queen c7 knight c6 fishing land fishing
Go Fish
they know it's coming Bishop blocks
can I do this this time no it's still
not working you baby yes we are in the
same exact we're playing the same exact
opposition as last game that we played
okay and how did that turn out
I didn't up win in that one but what a
struggle it was it's definitely a
struggle yeah it was a king and pond end
game that I ended up having to uh deal
with let me do this hopefully that
becomes a giant thorn let's do this oh
I'm dropping that pond by the way
dropping this pond and he's gone no he's
now he's protected Wow missing stuff
let's do this I get that pun I do this
King position where's the King position
King position is right here hang on hang
on there and what am i doing oh pigs
everywhere there's so many pigs right
here so many pigs
oh that ponds gonna go down oh I'm gonna
pin I'm in a pin I'm in a pin I'm in a
pin I'm in a pin I can't get out of a
pin unless they do that oh there's gonna
be rook check maybe we're not come on I
just want one Brooke off the board one
rook off come over here it's safer get
my king where oh they're gonna get that
pawn 17 seconds open this up here please
give me this pawn my rook wants some
activity finally my bishop wants to stay
on the board give the bish of my other
bishop wants to come over here my Brooke
wants to be on the seventh why am I
doing this
get over here entry points my king wants
to play get out of there bishop my rook
wants to play oh I shoulda hit this
right here right here right here my
bishop is stupid stupid bishop come over
here no over here give a check how much
time four point three I don't have any
time time tickers time tickers can I get
that Bishop pre moves
Primo's Primo's Primos
ah I can't breathe can't breathe I can't
breathe oh look I get I get I got it I
got it
Oh who's David Blaine in it again right
there I don't know why I do that I
should breathe I need some coaching
right there just breathe just breathe I
need I need somebody in my corner right
there just breathe it's okay come on
isn't anybody in the twitch chat saying
that I can't even look at the twitch
chat oh man just breathe it's gonna be
okay you can do it is anybody saying
that if you are I appreciate it
come on get to D 6 give a check even if
you drop a pond you get the rook I'm on
a rookie I'm gonna kill the pond
it seems right it seems so right but I'm
not gonna do it maybe next time okay I
could get it next time I'm gonna do it
now it's not working now let's try this
one Pig one Pig is it gonna be enough
watch out for your back rank don't you
dare come on flight square just grab
that pun shirt just grab that pun ah
don't go after that guy should just push
them let's come over here pawn push
anyhow oh man oh man it's scary it's
very very scary it's very very scary
what do I have I don't have anything I
got to do this no I got to do that oh oh
they're ready do mate they're ready to
get my rook they're gonna get my rook
somehow oh this is very dangerous I'm on
the rook please don't kill me it's gonna
give a check I could block get behind
here that pounds gonna push what am i
doing my bishop needs to defend
is this working I should have thrown in
a pawn check let's do it and pin a
knight I could be sneaky maybe kill the
night if they promote with the check and
I get the Queen I'm gonna do this anyhow
promote I don't have any time where's my
time oh I'm so dead can I get this in
I'm a dead man you can't come back from
this should I be trying to win this
stalemate
give me a stalemate please Oh give me a
checkmate oh that's a bad one ah man 17
minutes
I should have sacked on e6 when I had
the chance and the king went to f8 why'd
I second-guess myself this is one minute
I'm doing it next time I'm pulling the
trigger on that one oh man that one took
the wind out of me there I got knocked
to the canvas but I am coming back up
I'm back up after it to count after to
count I'm backing up backing up I'm back
up reap regroup you can do it you can do
it self pep talk it's always nice give
yourself a little self pep talk and
everything's gonna be warm and fuzzy
let's go Bishop play pawn push and this
pawn falls let's defend before it's too
late
alright let's come over here with the
rookie and let's finally get castled
okay okay I got this maybe let's throw
these guys down here can I get something
going on trapper ruski right here light
squares light square problems pin in my
opinon might pin a night and then it
undermine it that's the big plan I have
a center look to if you have control the
center look to play on the wings that's
what I'm gonna do each file is opening
up the knight has to run scared the
knight is under fire oh man right here
Queen check and then mate stuff or not
right here right here where is the mate
what's my King doing do something King
Bishop check don't run away King oh guy
should grab that pun Oh is the Queen
gonna give a check somewhere bishop here
bishop here and then look for maids
kill the night and then get the other
rook here oh I got this and give a check
first then I have this one okay they're
down on time back to time at 7970 huh oh
I would still be in first if I didn't
lose that one I think okay there's still
a lot of time in this tournament yes a
quick resigner did I get any points for
that yes I did 88 how many times I have
to click that refresh button okay the
starter I have a lead 88 - what somebody
has maybe 80 or 79 and I get that f2
real quick Queen b6 look for a quick
kill quick kill quick kill uh-huh that
was bad that was bad I shouldn't have
gone for that these are strictly for
bullet games trying these silly one move
threats don't do that not a good idea
let's come over here this might be a
good idea you know what I'm getting
ready for somebody is sniffing it out
right away they're like I know what you
have up your sleeve you've done it so
many times you will not fool me again oh
are you going Knight where are you going
oh oh oh oh big trouble big trouble
light square kilobyte square bishop Oh
Forks everywhere I just dropped my queen
why did I just drop my queen oh no oh
they're giving it back why they give it
back how did I drop my queen oh it
happens it happens push up on giving me
that's the plan push the pawn give a me
me right here that's me back to
tournament the tables turn how quickly
do the tables turn
1:08 79-77 71 13 minutes in change I
think everybody has a loss in this
tournament so far whoa
white square weaknesses everywhere can
somebody say white square weaknesses
light square weaknesses they are
everywhere and my opponent is managing
to close shop
here I don't want them to be closing
this position up here Queen e2 my knight
wants to get to f5 let's make it happen
it's gonna come with tempo now right
here actually I want the LightSquared
Bishop steuby off the board first can I
make that happen
unlikely let's do this so it's no longer
a whole anymore
let's do this I'm not sure why I did
that actually let's take here and then
take and then open the position up on
this I'm on the Queen
oh they dropped a clean I know that
feeling definitely know that feeling
Forks oh the rook could have blocked and
it would have defended the night I'm on
this rook unless the knight blocks and
if it does I don't okay right here
actually is working made threats oon we
have here okay is this working out I got
the night it's it and it cannot be
defended
do you not run away King this is matin
to just move back to chairman one 1:28
one or yeah 128 97 97 11 minutes and
change here we go
less than 20 or no I'm less than 12 okay
are they gonna fire this up here's the
clock if you're curious tick tock tick
tock the seconds are just going away
here okay they better just give me an
air with this one do not start up now if
you didn't start up right away you
better not start up right now let's go
let's go let's go come on they're
catching up they are making progress and
I am NOT here
we'll just hit me with the air please
just get it over with you know you want
an Eric to come up here in the meantime
where we at the standing still same
thing here's the clock if you're curious
11 minutes approaching okay enough with
that there's going to be an air very
soon I want to be in a spot to click out
of that stuff 117 Oh
closing the distance here 10 minutes and
change let's go come on this is this is
waiting too long for an air message to
come up let's go there we go there we go
there we go
refresh refresh refresh 138 oh okay what
do we have
Zeus Zeus ax playing again Zeus
how do you win against Zeus how do you
do that oh you get the night to start Oh
the Queen's head I'm not gonna keep
missing that did somebody like send out
a memo like this guy he drops his queen
go after it go after the Queen he'll
never defend the Queen if you attack it
give a check and then another check with
the bishop if the King runs queens are
coming off aren't they whoa that is a
crazy King queenside castle with the
check uh-oh
hit the Queen if the Queen right here is
a mate mate mate coming up on c7
just go here right here it's safe and
sound safe and sound on f7 right here
just
they are not moving I want a me where is
that mean oh that's me that's me that's
me that's a helpmate back to tournament
158 that was pretty quick
158 117 117 97 9 minutes and change I
could get paired up with either the
second and third place guy and that
could be very critical hang on hang on
secure the Queen position don't drop
your queen again oh hang on night they
were going after it man everybody's out
to get my Queen anymore they are testing
the waters they are wondering is he
gonna see it that the queen is being
attacked he didn't last time they're
saying Castle you know you want a castle
yes h2 power of suggestion you know you
want castle it happened
178 137 hack comic B 4d for fantasy
variation take it and then setting up
fishing going fishing very soon maybe
the key one of the key ingredients the
the night crawler is right here he's the
one that you end up needing to hook on
this little pool right here okay cleanup
queenside castle max actually I should
have played Age 3 before the Queen wolf
so if they take mine I tack recapture my
queen and maybe even Castle kingside or
Queen side anyhow they're not moving are
they gonna take my knight or allow me to
expand okay now I have the G file to
play with let me just castle rook here
unless my knight is attacked Bishop h6
coming up very soon open it up this is a
hook h5 coming up get out of there
Knight I need to play on the H file I'm
gonna do it anyhow open this up
o g6 coming under some heavy fire right
now
uh-oh big trouble is the King gonna hide
oh there isn't any bishop here mating -
threat Queen f7 - h7 many threats my
queen is lost if my rook wasn't there
okay I want to keep the Queen's on the
board making two threat it was pinned I
couldn't do
go there okay back to termit they
resigned 198 137 137 seven minutes and
change okay I have a 60 one-point lead
last warrior c5 okay do not capture I
don't want a symmetrical ponch structure
we're having a stone wall set up can I
break this down somehow I'm gonna try it
actually as crazy as it looks
let's get over here and let's do this
right now
get over here is this a bit too crazy
maybe maybe get that night away actually
let's see what its gonna do I'm Anna g2
if the Queen was still here that's a big
problem I want to get at that square
it's coming up very soon I think take
care and then take care the night takes
there's a deadly windmill windmill fun
times when it's a windmill
fun times oh not so fun time oh why did
I do that right here I'm not even sure
what that's doing aah
if the Queen goes too far maybe I could
do that or something right here what's
what am i doing with my rook Oh does
this work there's something to it I
think no it doesn't work I was thinking
that there was already a battery here
I'm on that night twice hit the Queen
okay I'm ready to take the knight and
then give me some how I take this Knight
takes okay the knight can't take this is
a mate too if the rook is taken or if
it's not taken that's it just move back
to chairman 218 207 how was sixty points
made up oh that's crazy of people
resigning if we're paired up that's
gonna be a big one it's gonna be a very
big one Wow
sixth I had a sixty one point lead
that's vanished now it's less than ten
or about ten
man that is a lot of points to be
winning that's nuts
absolutely nuts push this night away get
f4 castle should target that f7 pon a
lot soon I should've played 95 well I
had the chance now d6 is gonna be played
maybe what's the scoop they're not
moving betrayed I really want to just
smash through at that point c6 gonna be
played or is the rook gonna move or the
night okay let's back up I want to get
this in this this game is crawling right
now an additional reason why I would
want to move that night is so my queen
has some clearance if paan takes pawn
I'll play Queen hh5 looking for a Mane
that we hit three times defendant one
okay this is matin a few okay the King
has to move there where's the mate
though is this close to me I'm gonna
take my knight anything okay this isn't
made though it take here actually it's a
main to upon establish and then the
bishop check is mean that's me Mac
determined 2:38 what's the count what's
the count to 38 to 27 I think it's just
gonna come down to who could get that
last one in oh that's it's gonna come
down to can I get two more games in I
think I'm gonna need to manage two more
games come on do not quick resign to
that guy resigned to this guy right here
me I need the points
me here we go let's do it they're gonna
give up their dark square Bishop Bishop
b7 it's being launched okay even even
still I'm gonna do that I think okay
it's a little bit weird but I'm gonna
try it let's open this up right now I
should just take a nap on him on the
Queen now I could still do it and then
deflect the bishop away from the knight
okay actually that's that's pretty good
right there I want to get on this
diagonal mating one threat maybe if the
night plays here yes yes yes yeah
yes that's what I needed no I don't need
to I need to need a shirt okay that's I
needed a quick win Oh 258 247 how much
time just time for one more yes a quick
resigner zeus ax 278 247 oh here we go
here we go can I get this one more in if
I could get one more I think it'll be
sealed but who knows who really knows
for sure when you're up 61 points and
then it vanishes in a heartbeat and
everybody is going after that Queen of
mine everybody is out to kill that Queen
take it just take it take the bait just
take him he's free take him he's still
free isn't he okay looks I'm on the
night I could take the night now because
of the pin on the D file I'm on the
night how much time is left 204 okay
there's gonna be time for this one to be
a win on this oh no no no no mate -
meeting - OH
get out of there bishop okay wait wait I
want to take care cuz this pawn is
pinned oh no no that's no good okay
maybe it's okay mate threats soon mate
threats right here on G - that's mate
that's mate that's mate that's mate back
to chairman 298 267 one minute 30
can I get one more in one more just to
make sure somehow 127 127 okay well can
we have here
take care and that's castle or not just
Castle please black just castle just
castle it's safe night here please
oh man Queen check is available let's do
this I want to get to c5 see if they get
up there dark square Bishop how much
time a minute left a minute - oh man oh
it's I should have taken the night okay
I don't want a castle I don't want this
night to move and do it with check in
other word
now let's do this I'm gonna go with the
pond actually I want to defend this
somehow that's not really defending
great oh I'm getting crunched
okay wait 38 seconds maybe I should just
be trying not to lose here oh I didn't I
should be just capturing that pond open
this up here right here pins pins right
here oh not really
okay this isn't gonna happen I'm not
gonna win this 23 seconds hopefully
hopefully where's my nearest competitor
wait this might actually be close to
mate somehow come on get that check mate
threat mate threat is there mate there
mate there mate four seconds four
seconds four seconds what do I got first
oh I needed every game that I got right
there first place confetti barely what
were the final standings right here whoa
298 287 oh man good games Oh